warring parties in Ethiopia have signed
a deal allowing humanitarian supplies
into the war-torn Tigre region it comes
after a recent peace deal was reached
between the sides with the focus now
shifting to Aid and disarmament
handshakes and hugs signal another
hopeful day for Ethiopia leaders from
the government and tigrain Rebels coming
together to end the brutal conflict
which has displaced millions of people
with a peace deal signed 11 days ago in
Pretoria both sides have now decided to
open up humanitarian corridors
we want to express our full commitment
for praying peace and the stability to
our people and Country
therefore we fully dedicate our service
to increment
the creatory argument and this narration
the conflict began in November 2020 less
than a year after Ethiopian Prime
Minister ABI Ahmed won the Nobel Peace
Prize for making peace with Eritrea
Eritrean Fighters have since been
fighting alongside Ethiopian federal
troops in tigray
Saturday's agreement commits to grind
forces to give up their heavy weapons
and foreign forces to withdraw from the
region
today is
the agreement allows for immediate
humanitarian access to all in need in
tigry and its neighboring regions a
crucial step towards a more peaceful
future
we're now joined by Samuel garaju who is
a journalist in the Ethiopian Capital
artist Ababa so Samuel does this mean
that the conflict is over or could there
be stumbling blocks ahead
well it it means it's over especially on
a piece of paper on a document but it's
an open question whether the people will
actually accept it on the ground there
has been misgivings even from the TPL
left side some saying the TPL left
needed to fight more some saying that
they needed to compromise so this
conflict has been a wage issue among
Ethiopians and that's what we're seeing
at the moment
so what pitfalls exactly do you see in
the agreement
well um you know some of the agreed in
terms of disarming tplf which is
overwhelmingly supported by a majority
of Ethiopians isn't accepted by people
in tigray the people in tigray have said
they've suffered enough they wanted the
tplf to even fight more
um and it's really really a wage issue
even if you speak to the people in the
cafes and the restaurants in Ethiopia
they will tell you different
versions of it saying that the Ethiopian
government either needed to go all the
way to mckelley and defeat tplf in which
they have declared the organization as a
terrorist organizations some of the
tigrants are saying that the TPL left
needed to fight needed to be supported
perhaps the U.N has been accused of
supporting tplf including the Biden
Administration so again it's a real like
all conflicts in the world this conflict
is no exception it's a wage issue among
Ethiopians again all right now the lack
of humanitarian access has been a huge
problem in the region has anything there
changed since the warring parties agreed
on the ceasefire 11 days ago
well the Ethiopian government has
insisted that they've opened a
humanitarian Corridor and Aid is being
allowed to go to segurai and the U.N
agencies are saying that's not what's
happening on the ground they still don't
have the kind of humanity and quoted
that they need to really save lives once
again famine is coming back to this
country a famine that defined this
country in the 1980s is becoming its
reality now many people are still facing
famine millions are looking for some
kind of support that the U.N has been
saying they don't even have the
resources to help them but they really
want to try go in and save lives but
this is no exception to tigray it's also
happening in amhara and afar and
according to the U.N about 13 million
Ethiopians are facing famine as a direct
result of this conflict
the right that was Samuel gadachu a
journalist reporting for us from thank
you for bringing us up to date
thank you thank you